COMMITTEE FOR THURSDAY MARCH
TWENTY SECOND MICHAEL ORDER.
PLEASE FEEL NUYS ADVICE OF THE
AUDIENCE RECORDING OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDING IS BEING MADE. AND AS
ALSO BEING TELEVISED. AMOUNT
SECTOR GROUPS CALLED RULES
COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM HERE
ALLEN. BROKE HERE CARILLO AFTER
MANTEGNA FRIEDMAN GRAYSON HERE
AS ARIANNA SOLACE
WALDRON WE HAVE A BLAST.
WE HAVE A QUORUM. WE HAVE A
CONSENT AGENDA WATER NOTE
HOWEVER THAT WE ARE MOVING AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY FIVE BY
MISTER BONTA FROM HER FOR ALL
THIS THIS MORNING.
I IS OUR MOST ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA. SECOND MOVES TO CUT IN
FRONT OF US GRAYSON.
A MEASURE TO INCREASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM AYE ALLEN
BROUGH. BROUGH AYE CARILLO AND
CARILLO EYES AROUND US.
CERVANTES AYE FRIEDMAN GRAYSON
AYE GRAYSON AYE NAZARIAN SOLIS
WALDRON. MUCH PASSAGE.
THE MOTION PASSES AND THIS.